number of three walks in above so this
is basically you know lose access or
count the number of ABCD for which you
can go maybe to be b2c and C to D but
but what this means that there could be
you know a secret you can go A to B and
B back to a in which I would be count as
C right because there was no restriction
that CNA have to be different okay so
this query will be very much different
from a query where you actually want to
count the
paths where there's no repetition
if you if you really want the actual
path then you have to do something like
that
now here you see that I'm I'm changing
the the logic a little bit so um so here
I'm going to think of every Edge
relation as a function
that will map to one if the edge exists
and zero otherwise and if I would like
to do the counting I also need to say
that a is different from B from c d you
know or ABCD are all different so there
will be a lot more complicated stuff
going on here with this indicator
functions
uh but if you sum up over all possible
ABCD that should give you the number of
three uh walks or three parts
this is um a more complex query than the
the one before
uh I am not going to show you the the
rail code of this it looks exactly the
same as the
um is that logic okay
and later on you know when Val and Dan
talked about
um you know an algebraic language uh um
with the semi-ring then you will see
stuff like this occurring very naturally
in so this is not logic anymore right
this is something that you can do
Algebra with
um and yeah so I'm trying to in in this
introduction to connect all of the talks
that you will see in this boot camp
together and you're starting to this
would start to show up
um another problem is say own pairs
shortest path right so in English you
want to say that well compute is what is
partling between every pair of vertices
uh so here you will need kind of another
query language in order to to express
this problem right and uh the one that
above and done we'll talk about uh is uh
something called Data logo where you
will Express the problem much like in ma
uh in this way so you will say that well
the query says uh compute for me the
shortest path between X and Y that's
going to be the minimum between the
length of the The Edge from X to y or a
minimum over all possible Z for which
the length from X to Z it's this much
and then you add the length from
from Z to Y so but for this query there
are actually two at least two different
ways to express it right you can also
you know start with the same base case
but then in the recursion you could
recourse it on two uh you know Q X to Z
and Q Z to Y so then mathematically
there are two ways to express this
problem and it turns out that if
rail a system C is this query it's
actually not completely trivial if you
express it in a way that is not very
easy to optimize
so you could you could express you know
the own pressure this path problem this
way
uh this will be the first way this is
called uh linear recursion where
I hope you can see this on
from the back uh where you know it's
exactly like the math formulation you
know open very shortest path but this
this Q occurs only once in the query
sometimes you could have you could
express it so that it occurs twice and
it's actually harder to optimize
um in in some ways and then the first
one
um and then you could actually query
this graph so this is the same graph
right typically people doing it are not
interested in all possible you know
shortest battling between own pairs of
vertices and a graph you have nine
million vertices uh that would be nine
million by nine million for whatever two
millions right uh there's who has the
time to examine you know uh 4 trillion
pairs of vertices usually they are
interested in something very specific
about this query so you could ask a
query well um what is the so let's say I
I want to query this uh you know from
vertex number two
what is the shortest path link to all of
the rest of the graph okay so this would
be the single Source the shortest path
problem
and
um and then in the output you wanna you
may want to ask well what is the maximum
distance from this number two to the
rest of the graph okay
and then if I run this it should give me
something sort of like the diameter of
the graph but Center at this vertex too
and if you arrange this over over this
is you get the actual diameter so in
this case it returns seven or so so the
graph has a pretty small diameter
but you can see that the query returns
very quickly
and that's thanks to demand
transformation which is another topic
that Annie Liu who's here earlier who
might give you a talk on
um
and uh the the idea is that you can
compute something like this without
actually
Computing all possible pairs you know
nine trillion or whatever
output size so that's another query
optimization problem
okay so with these examples you probably
some were convinced that um you know
there are all these queries that all of
you have been looking at and you know if
they are backed into a relational
database system then the optimizer the
query Optimizer has to process those
queries and return the answer come up
with a query plan as quickly as possible
so that's a very brief introduction to
the query optimization and evaluation
problem yeah
okay so the main problem looks something
like this so we have a query
um
and then we have a database that stores
you know like the ash relational graph
and we also have some statistics on the
data that are in the database
I'm going to call this SD the
statistical profile of the data in a
database and then we would like to
return the answer to the query
okay so the problem is given q and d uh
compute QD is in the most efficient you
know and there I say optimal way
possible
optimality is a very very strong word I
don't want to claim that but let's see
how far we can push this notion
and uh if we have let's say some kind of
update to the database so you remove an
edge from the graph you add in a new
Edge to the graph given the same query
is it possible to compute the output of
the query without recomputing the whole
thing
so in database done on Friday it's going
to talk about
incremental view maintenance and I guess
in algorithms this is called Dynamic
algorithms and we do have a workshop
with a few talks later in September on
Dynamic algorithms so that's IBM problem
I think it's basically is the same the
same problem
okay so to make this formulation a
little more precise and then I have to
tell you what I mean by a query
and in in this talk and the next two
we'll be focusing mostly on phone
conjunctive queries and a little
generalization called the sum product
query and some product query is a
concept that we borrowed from from Ai
and in one of the tutorials ghee and
Eugene will talk more about you know an
AI and inquiry evaluation on circuit
that has a lot to do with some product
type of computation
there are other other types of queries
say first order second order
uh of which I don't know if you can ask
focus on to give a talk on complexity of
different types of inquiry classes
I'm trying to to get you know topics
line up for the rest of the semester
um then that would be it uh we have
Nichols who can give you ranking
enumeration talk
um different types of queries many
different types of Aquatics they are
very practical uh extremely useful
what is in the statistical profile uh so
in in my talk I'll be just talking about
one particular one the condo degree
concerns is sufficiently simple but also
quite powerful enough to build a
database on
but there are many other concerns uh
frequency movement constraints uh
histogram
samples you can sample from the database
and Marcelo on Friday you'll give a talk
on sampling in a database and you could
have you could build machine learning
model about the data and then you'll
learn something and use that information
to optimize queries
uh what do I mean by optimality well um
so for this talk and macmost talk we'll
be talking about worst case optimality
and instance optimality but in general
we'll need A fine grain complexity uh
folks to to tell us more about various
ways who you know how do you prove that
uh the answer to this query is it's
optimal in some way you have to make
some complexity or theoretic assumption
so on Virginia Nicole and jinjang are on
Wednesday and Thursday will give you
some flavor of that
and most importantly I'm not sure if you
realize this is that
um in the picture that I showed you
earlier
the query Optimizer does not optimize
you have to kind of code up the
optimizer before you see the query
so there are two ways to do this right
you you might want to say well if the
query is a triangle I'm going to run
this algorithm if the query is a four
cycle I'm going to run this algorithm
but the number of queries is infinite in
you when you code up the optimizer you
cannot have an if then else you know
like that right the optimizer has to be
in some sense Universal and it'll have
to work for every query so the optimizer
has to be done before we see the query
and this is a very subtle and important
Point
um and in in some ways is basically is a
meta algorithm you know given a
description of the problem is supposed
to Output an algorithm it is uh to to
solve the query
and so um in my three tutorials I'm
going to be talking about basically
three basic meta algorithms so the first
one is join it's actually a meta
algorithm a second one borrowed heavily
from
um from the AI Community for machine
learning uh is the variable elimination
technique which is a very highly generic
way of solving a query and then tensor
decomposition so those are very
general techniques that can be applied
to a bunch of different problems
including all of the problems that you
have seen just now
okay so that's basically the outline of
the rest of the talks and the tutorial
okay any questions so far
all right so let's go to the first
problem
this will be on cardinality bounds and
most guys often will join
um
so this is a little bit of a detour in
in some sense but you will see
eventually how this is actually tightly
connected to query evaluation so this is
our problem we have a database and we
have a you know a profile some kind of
samplings or some kind of statistics
about the data in the database like the
degree of you know vertices in the graph
or the number of edges in the graph and
so on
and um let's say we would like to know
the following let's forget about
answering the query to begin with let's
just say that I would like to estimate
an upper bound on the output size of
this query
so if we were to list all of the
triangles in the graph
then this will be saying that well if I
know the number of edges on the graph
can I get an estimate on the maximum
number of triangles that we can get
so this is a much simpler query than
than in that query but let's see if we
can get this you know maximum estimation
this is in database this is extremely
useful because for example if you knew
this you could use it to let's say cap
the memory amount that you will use in
answering the query for
this can be used for cardinality
estimation which is a very important
component in a query optimizer
so I will kind of try to simplify the
question and then later on it will go
back to answering the action query
now um so that's one notion of
optimality
which will come back to in the second
lecture on our second tutorial which is
worst case optimality
and most guys optimality basically says
that um The Following so suppose that we
somehow knew uh how to answer this this
question
then a join algorithm is an algorithm
that can answer this query in time
that the input size does you know the
input database right plus the worst case
output size
so this is not quite instance optimal in
a sense this is not QD but it is
um the worst case output among all of
the possible databases for which
um it has exactly the same statistics as
this profile so the idea is that we are
not going to process the query over the
database we are only looking at the
statistics let's say you know the number
of edges of the graph or something or
number of vertices of the graph and
um get the query to run in time that is
the worst case of possible
so there's there's actually some input
for which this algorithm is is
instance optimal right
it's a pretty weak notion of optimality
but let's see if we can actually get
here
So when you say card in that is it
that's cardinality of QD so it's like
the number of things that satisfy the
query
it's the number of tuples
um
okay so let's say you know the query was
listing all the triangles in the graph
then this will be the number of
triangles uh the runtime would be number
of triangles and you know that will be
like m to the 1.5 for example and the
runtime would be uh over 1.5
okay
like vertical equals uh in the subscript
oh yeah uh sorry uh thanks for the
question the question was what is this
notation this notation means um this is
a maximum over or possible databases D
Prime
Which models which has the same
statistics as uh SSD so like all
possible graphs that has exactly the
same number of of edges let's say you
know
um yeah so this means satisfies or model
is the logic notation go ahead
so they can be small
uh yeah so it depends on what we mean by
this profile so I will come to
will be arbitrary
so uh it is then not in time just in uh
it is
so if we don't have any information
about the database then the maximum
notebook size is
okay so um for the query so for now
let's just focus on core congenital
queries what does that mean it means
that it is the query in which all the
variables uh uh appear in the in the
output
so in a graph database that will be like
this
the body and then in the head of the
query
you want all possible
you know triangles for example or in a
movie database you would like all the
variables like director active movies
and so on
uh so there's no like access something
what that means it will project away
some of the variables right so for now
let's just focus on queries for which
every variable has in the head of the
web
and then we'll remove this assumption uh
in in the coming tutorials
okay so the more generally the model is
like this so we are given a hypograph
in which for every hyper Edge there is
an atom or there's a relation for that
type of edge
and we would like to answer the
following uh following query
um list all of the two posts that
satisfies every single atom in in the
body so the simplest example is the
hypergraph in this case it's just a
triangle and then we would like own two
post ABC for which a B is in E ICS
but in general this this hypogram could
be uh like in the previous example uh it
could be this hypograph is you know has
an edge direct director actor or actor
movie uh actor Asian and so on
technically technically this might not
be considered a conjunctive query but
for the purpose of this talk
um think of this as a Content inquiry
because of this disjunction here but for
the purpose of this talk you can think
of this uh as as a relation you know
this is a relation on on the variable
actor H but it has to be you know more
than 20 or different from 10
you could have a regular expression
matching relation too and that's fine
for the purpose of this talk
okay so hopefully this model is okay
with you we will have maybe a few more
examples but it's important to get the
model in mind that we are given a
hypograph which captures the structure
of the query every hyper Edge there's a
corresponding relation and then uh um
the query is you know list for me all of
the output tuples that satisfy the
relation
that are captured by the hyper edges in
okay so so that defines the query and
the next uh topic is what is in the
statistical profile
and we are going to focus on just one
notion it's going to degree constraints
and what is our degree constraint so
imagine we have a relation like this uh
this is a ternary relation that has
three variables actor movie and role
right
and let's imagine we have a a vector uh
on the actor variable in which we are
going to count for every actor how many
rows of the table the actor occurs in
so here we have uh you know our list
occurs in one Bob in four and Carol in
two
this is a humongous relation still
because the number of actors is you know
maybe in the millions also so this will
not be in our statistical profile
our profile is going to be some kind of
summary of this Vector it will be a norm
and in this case I'm going to just use
the infinity Norm of this vector
so this Infinity Norm this Vector is
going to be 4 right because so Bob
occurs in four movies and that's the the
maximum
so so this constraint is called a degree
constraint it says that
um every actor occurs in at most four
rows in this table
um okay now in general instead of this
actor we are going to have
um you you could have for example a
vector on actor and movie together okay
so in this case for every combination of
actor and movie how many rows of this
table does this uh active movie
belong
so so this is a different degree
constraint and assume that if this
Infinity Norm is 1 then in database this
is called a functional dependency
this says that for every actor and movie
I know and there's only one row assuming
uh then this is a functional dependency
you could also have a group by of
nothing so this says that you know given
nothing the infinity infinity Norm of
the count in this case it will be seven
because we are counting everything
we are not grouping by actor or actor
movie or anything so in this case this
is called the cardinality constraint
it's the size of the of the table
so this attraction even though very very
simple is actually quite powerful
because you can use it to capture a lot
of very common statistics that you would
have in a database so if this was at the
edge relation of a graph then you might
want to say well D of u u is you know
you have UV as vertices right so D of U
Infinity that will be the maximum degree
in a graph
right or if you have the empty set
Infinity then that will be the number of
edges in the graph
okay
oh uh
uh yes I think so so I usually use both
Facebook and then uh the component of
the character is not involved
yeah so so secure the actor is still the
vector you know we're just looking at us
so this is just a component a component
okay so in general uh a degree
constraint is a triple x y and n uh in a
relation R and what it says is that
for every X
the number of different y's is bounded
by n
so um this is a general decreases right
all right for every X the number of
different y's is bounded uh
and these will be our Central subject of
the statistical profile that we have in
the database
across two relations what would you do
with the inclusion dependency do you
have this in the optimizer uh yeah so
the focus question is in general how do
we deal with constraints that do not
correlate but they spend across table
uh my general answer is that we don't
know in general is pretty pretty hard to
deal with those instruments now typical
typically optimizers deal with those by
doing sampling because yeah beforehand
you might have a query in which you ask
for uh you know the mic to be
Honda and the
manufacturer to be Honda and the market
will be Civic or something and if they
belong to different table and you're
asking this query
beforehand it's extremely hard to know
beforehand that these two sound strongly
correlated right so you basically have
to kind of sample into the database to
know for sure that the output is only
one you know for every Honda there's a
or for a every Civic there's only one
Honda we don't we don't have that that
kind of uh model to model those
situations um
I think that's a great open question
actually there are much more powerful
concerns that we need to be able to
capture in a database at this formalism
just doesn't
okay so now we know the constraints
right and let's go back to our question
what is the maximum cardinality of the
of the output satisfying these
constraints
and in order to describe one approach uh
to answer this question uh we'll look at
a hierarchy of set functions so I'm
going to look into a collection of set
functions uh
on actually this was supposed to be V
the set of variables in a query
and we'll look at the ones for which
which are non-negative and monotone so
you know each of the empty set is zero
and then if x is a subset of Y then h of
X is a subset of H of Y and then as we
are adding more and more constraints to
these sets we are narrowing down this
collection of set functions so for
example you can have a sub additive
functions where satisfy this inequality
the one that is most important to us is
a submolar submodular function so
um is both non-negative monotone and
submodular which means you satisfy this
inequality
and there's a class of functions called
entropic functions which are basically
entropies of some discrete distributions
and then as we are moving down uh in at
the very end at the bottom of this
hierarchy is a set of modular function
which is very very simple h of X is the
sum of H of the elements in
these have to be non-negative
and so the thing that I would focus on
in a little bit is the poly Matrix or
submodular non-uh sub modular functions
that are monotone and non-negative and
you will see how they show up in proving
about for for this query
um just in a moment
okay so remember that we are interested
in this quantity what is the maximum
output size of a query over all
databases satisfying a given collection
of degree constraints so SD is what we
know and we want to maximize over uh you
know all of the D Prime to satisfy the
same degree concerns
and for
um uh convenience we will actually up
about the lock of this quantity
you will see why in in a moment
now there's something called the
combinatorial bound which will be an
exact equality uh it's probably
computable but impractical and now it's
like why and then because of that we
will have a hierarchy of bounds that
will kind of approximate this as much as
possible
and the one that we'll be focusing on is
polymer
and now I'll have an example to explain
where all these bounds come from
actually only these two parts and we'll
ignore the rest of the boat
okay so let's look at one example for
them
[Music]
what do you mean exactly like that yeah
I'll give you an example and uh you'll
see yeah
that's right it depends entirely on what
s is that's right yeah
yeah for some as we actually don't know
for simple SSM is probably
one example
did you ever question yes I was
wondering what was
oh uh yeah so I'm not going to have time
to extend this um this is just a
variable
is the parameter
okay okay so let's look at them
extremely simple example uh
uh and many of us work on click queries
and you know triangle
and this will hopefully
resonate with you
so in this case uh the database consists
of consists of three relations or s and
t right RAB SBC and Tac
um or CA doesn't matter
and our statistical profile
has the cardinalities of these three
relations so our ascentives so it's just
like the edge relation of
you know the number of edges but nothing
else
um now here is where uh in a database
setup
the this is a construent satisfaction
problem right because you you want to
know a number of triples that satisfy
all three constraints but in a database
um the difference is that typically the
number of concerns is small you know in
a query you don't have a lot of
constraints right you have I don't know
up to 10 50 relations or so but every
constraint is very very large like you
know the edge relation of a graph could
be like billions of tuples in it so
please have this model in mind that the
it's very vertical right instead of a
horizontal as in a constraint
satisfaction problem it's quite
horizontal because the number of
constraints is very very high
um okay so now the question is how do we
bound the output size of this way
so here's the combinatorial part that we
can we can set up so let's say that we
have an indicator variable for the fact
that uh you know ABS in our AC is in s
and BC is in t now obviously this is a
triangle if all three indicator
variables are one right
and so if you sum over that then you
will get the number of triangles
and the cardinality constraints will be
well the sum over all of the indicators
for R is less than r uh for shs and S
and for T is less than t
those are the the main constraints we
have uh billions of indicator variables
uh this is kind of a horrible integer
programming problem you can turn this
into a linear integer program but it
doesn't help because the number of
variables this is too it's just too big
so this is what I meant by uh computable
but impractical
but this is only for uh you know this
kind of very very simple constraint so
as Brian pointed out if you change this
General Degree concern it's not obvious
how you set it even
but even here how you this how do you
define the variables in this in this
problem rather for example how where
does a B A and B range over right yeah
precisely so you so even here
compatibility is
I guess you could do this here because
you know that the the domain or the
active domain of this relation About It
by R and sat so by an isomorphism
argument you can assume that you know a
ranges from one to you know are and so
on so you can make some kind of
assumptions
but in general it seems to be pretty
healthy
um
okay so that's the combinatorial plant
now uh so the next round uh is based on
the entropy argument and this came from
uh probably even earlier by a famous
paper fanchon Ron Graham Franco and
Shira and it goes like this so let's
actually
fix a worst case input for this query so
RS and T
and for this word size input we will get
a table of triples on Q right it's
probably a pretty big table
but it's going to be finite so let's
select a tuple
a b and c in Q uniformly at random so
this is for the worst case input right
so it could be a queue could have
trillions of octopus let's just select
one to pull out uniformly at random
so what do we know about this
distribution
well we know that because it's uniform
the the entropy of that distribution is
going to be log of the support right
and the support because this voice guys
input is exactly the quantity we're
interested in
so that's the quantity and log of the
support is H of ABC
and the marginal entropies will be less
than log of the support of the
projections of this distribution onto uh
onto s and onto t
because the uniform distribution has the
maximum entropy and so this will be less
than the three logs right and finally
the most important concern is that H as
a function it has to be entropic
so the notation for entropic function is
gamma star 3. this has become kind of
standard in information Theory so do not
ask me why you know
okay so um
it's entropic function this is a
function over uh
think of it as a vector that has seven
dimension
because HIV
c h b c h a b c h a b and c and so on
for every subset of three variables
there's an entropy value so H is
actually a vector
Dimension seven okay
um and it has to be entropic and how do
you characterize this region that's a
humongous problem in information Theory
but at least we can set it up you know
this optimization problem it doesn't
seem to help because you know we have we
have just turned a problem that seems to
be very hard into another problem that's
also seems to be pretty hard
um but uh is everything okay so far so
this is just an upper bound
it'll it'll be easier from from here on
computationally anyways
okay so uh
the next quantity oh uh what do I say so
this was an equality right so there's
not an upper bound or anything yet
this is for one particular
um uh entropic function so we know that
there exists an entropic function for
which we have an equality
so in order to have an upper bound all
we do is to optimize this over all
possible entropic functions
that that'll be our up about right so
this will become less and equal to the
max over all its possible entropic
functions
right so this is uh the entropic bomb
that's the first bound in our hierarchy
we're going to go down this hierarchy
and the next relaxation uh is that well
because characterizing entropic function
seems to be pretty pretty hard so what
we do is we relax it a little further uh
instead of taking entropy function we'll
take poly metroids which is just one
layer up so here we have uh you know
monotone non-negative and submodular
function
and the beauty of this is that the
polymer choice or they have linear
constraints
so now we can Zone them now right
because remember monotonic city is just
you know h of X and less than h of Y is
a linear constraint submodularity all of
them are linear
except that this dimensionality of this
Vector is exponential
right because for every subset of the
set of variables we have one component
of this vector
it's exponential however it's
exponential in the query size and as I
said earlier in databases the query is
pretty narrow the data is big but the
query has like three variables you know
50 variables whatever based potential in
50 is is you know impossible but still
in principle is is a lot smaller than
than the billion variables that we have
okay so this this is our polymer bound
for the triangle queries
and
yeah so the the main lesson so far is
that this bound uh is a linear program
so it's really in principle you can
compute it
oh no so this is beyond almost entropic
yeah I didn't say anything about all the
almost entropic yet
um but the the reason is that in general
in higher Dimension
um the region of entropic functions is
uh is not even closed so you can
actually have to detect the topological
enclosure of that and it will become the
set of almost integral functions but we
are not doing any optimization over that
we even relax it even further into the
set of polymatories so that we have
actually a handle on how to solve this
optimization problem
foreign
yeah because we actually set up an
optimization problem over this set but
this set seems to be very hard to
characterize even after you take the
topological enclosure it's still hard to
characterize so we move it up one one
more level
okay so from the entropy argument we got
the polymetary bar which is great so now
let's actually connect this to a few
more bounds that we know
so that's this very cute idea from lovaz
uh from a long time ago I think like
1982 or something
uh it goes like this
so so how here we have uh this
optimization problem maximizing h of ABC
subject to these three constraints and H
is in gamma 3 which is a set of entropic
functions I mean a polymatory is over
three variables this is our problem so
far as the polymer bound
um so Lobos came up with the following
idea
so suppose that we Define a modular
function remember that modular function
is a function where G of X is the sum
over G of the elements in x
um it's a very very simple
characterization
um and it goes like this so let's define
G of a to be h of a
G of B to be h of B given a so this is
um much like a conditional entropy which
means I should probably write something
so
page of me given a is equal to H of a b
minus
so that's exactly how a conditional
entropy is defined
uh
and similarly G of C is H of ABC minus h
of a b it's a conditional entropy of C
given a b
so we have now three numbers uh AGB and
GC we have three numbers so now you can
verify that for these three numbers
uh Gab
because it's modular so it's GI plus GB
so this is H of a b by definition
and then GBC is GB plus GC uh uh and my
sub modularity of H this will be smaller
than h of BC
by definition and then G of AC is
smaller than h of AC
by sub modularity of H
and so what this means is that g is a
modular function that satisfies all
three of the constraints at each
uh were supposed to satisfy because they
are even lower right G of a b is smaller
than Hib GBC smaller than HBC and so on
and modular function R uh poly Matrix
they are a special class of volumetrics
so we have found a smaller class of
functions within the class of
polymetoids for which
G of ABC is H of ABC because you can
telescope the sum from here to here
right so it has exactly the same
objective it satisfy the same
constraints but it is smaller
so that's great
that means that we can now just solve
the problem over the class of modular
functions instead of polymer
and because we installed this over the
module function the linear program now
has only poly size because there's only
one variable for every variable of the
original problem
this is a a lot easier constraint to a
problem to solve so that's the module
about
um
okay and so if you write that down this
is nothing but a vertical worth
expecting linear program
right it's a Vertex packing linear
program if you take the Dual of that you
will get a fraction of edge cover linear
program and that was basically what
Albert and uh
uh and gray and Max in 2008 in a fox
paper
um has a lot of influence in the story
I'm telling you
so if you take the Dual this is linear
program then you get the fractional Edge
cover linear program to bound the same
thing
okay so this is uh
um
basically you have a coefficient for
every edge of the graph and then for
every vertex the sum of the coefficients
have to be greater than one and then the
bond will be going to be this and if you
take the exponential of this it'll be
like R to dilemma or s to the Lambda s
and Theta Lambda t Okay so that's the
refreshment that bounds the number of
triangles in in the Curve
okay so um
you could go a little further and you
say that well uh you can also take the
integral Edge cover bound you know it's
kind of a silly thing to do because you
will get an uh even a bigger bomb right
because if you remove the constraint
then the Min will you know
uh the main shoot in Greece yeah the
mean will increase so um but it will be
uh somewhat interesting to point out
later on that this integral Edge cover
bound has kind of an um a database
interpretation so that's that's all I
wanted to point out
okay so what we have seen so far we have
seen so far that for the triangle
example this is only for the triangle
query
the quantity we're interested in can be
bounded by the entropic bound which
turns out to be equal to uh to the other
um
okay so the next the question is how
tight are on the bounds so um because
um
just for this example but you haven't
shown this wire or
I mean you said that the entropic one
was hard to compute but for this
particular example it's possible
is this what you mean oh oh I see so you
are
yeah so I have been shown uh that the
entropic bone is actually equal to to
this project right yeah and it's very
specific to this example
so it turns out that you can prove that
uh gamma 3
the polymerase and the envelope equation
are exactly the same it's just so
happened for this example
in general uh this will have to be an
inequality
okay so uh because we are kind of
running a little short on time I'm not
going to show the law about argument
but I want to at least get to the end
story that I would like to convey is
that that exact same argument that we
have seen so far is going to work for
General Degree constraints
uh remember degree conference is
basically the collection of triples x y
and N which says that for every for
every X that most and wise so that's the
collection of degree constraints right
and
um the exact same argument is going to
imply that uh you know the quantity
we're interested in is bounded by the
entropy bar
okay what does that mean well it
precisely means the following so given
the degree constraints
and from the real quick and friends we
are going to turn them into a linear
constraint on the um
on this polymetoid or entropic function
H so h of Y given X is less than equal
to log n you see that it's very easy to
turn one into the other right one is
combinatorial and one is information
theoretic
and once we have this bound then you can
the bound that we are interested in is
going to be an optimization problem over
this is the almost entropic region and
this is the you know these constraints
right here okay and we take we are
taking the soup over h of V so this
quantity is called the entropic bound
and if we relax this to only poly
Metroid then we get the polymer bar
and this bound is computable it's just a
linear program so it's great
uh and one simple example you know going
back to the triangle query if you are
going to take the polymatory bond then
you will get for example you know this
the number of triangles is less than n
to the 1.5
uh sometimes this is known as a Loomis
Whitney inequality
we just plug it into the bound and say
in the uniform you'll get uh
the variables
back there to one half you would recover
the same thing yeah thanks uh you're
right you have a bunch of variables and
their their pairs have to there's some
of the pairs have to be at least
so we don't really have to solve the
oftenization problem but in a feasible
solution and we can
in the previous slide what is the
Assumption of the query and every full
conjunctive period
oh yes uh this query has
for this talk
and then later
okay so this is kind of a trivial
example but there are other examples
that are not that actually you know
let's see oh okay so so suppose you also
have a triangle query but in a database
typically you will know that uh you know
some variables are key variables like
primary key in a relation right so for
example if you knew that b implies C uh
so B is a key so that means that there's
a functional dependency from B to C
now in this case
um the extra constraint that we have is
a the conditional entropy of C given B
is zero
right so we have one extraction and you
plug in the bound it's you know
constraints that just like before with
this one extra one but now the bound
drops significantly so in instead of
enter the 1.5 now we just get n
so this is corresponding to the out
degree of B is one and it has just an
edge
and of course this works even if the
obviously is three or five you know we
just plug in the log uh we need a lot
right here
just by solving a linear program but
this time I guess you have to solve it
it's not obviously
[Music]
yeah this is one of my favorite examples
it's extremely simple uh in database
sometimes you write queries like this
you know what is r a and SB and a plus b
is equal to five
and like the simplest example that
illustrates the strength of this bound
so here you will know that you know
given eight and then you have B given B
then you have a and uh this degree
constraint comes from this little
relation a plus b is equal to five
and if you plug in this you know a
conditional entropy then you will get
um you're bound to be the minimum of r
and s
so as a human Reasoner you would be able
to infer this right uh just say that
well do you have a conjunction of R and
S and then there's an FDA going A to B
in B to a and obviously the size of the
output is a minimum of two quantities
but the the entropy argument gives you
that kind of automatically
just as good as we would reason
okay so that sets up the bounds and
there are other examples
so now let's go to a research question
so I have about three minutes left and
um and there are infinitely many
research questions and here are some of
them
so the first thing is uh it's actually
open whether or not the entropic bond is
computable
we think it's not computable but we
don't know and Dan can give you uh you
know an overview of where we are with
with these entropic bounds
the second question is this is extremely
annoying we worked on this for some time
uh is the polymer bound even in p time
so at the surface of it the volumetric
bound is you know a linear program over
an exponential number of variables and
constraints so it should not even be in
p
but we also have seen examples such as a
triangle example you go from polymatory
to modular
and it certainly is in p
so uh you know is it the same in the
general case or not we don't know
um
and if it is not in P we you know we
have some good reason to conjecture that
is not in P then what are the classes of
inputs for which it should be because
it's very important in database to be
able to do cardinality estimation uh in
within p time
uh and then
the structure of the constraint somehow
and then when a switchbound
asymptotically tight
so we know that if the input has only
cardinality insurance and it is
basically tight but it's not definitely
tight I think Albert in the AGM paper
showed that even approximating the
compound is
like I'm hard assuming VPD hardness or
something like that so um yeah
it's not a completely trivial thing to
even set this up properly
uh yeah and then approximate about the
efficiently
um what about Beyond conjunctive queries
and the Aquarius
and then you know degree concern is just
really one set of instruments
and we deal with more interesting
constraints so what mode can give you a
talk on adding conditional Independence
constraints so that gives the structure
of the query quite a different flavor
um a frequency moment constraints
histogram concerns in database is very
common to have histogram so you will say
that well for this range of vertices in
the graph the maximum degree is five for
a different range of vertices in a graph
the maximum degree is seven and so on so
you divide a graph into different
communities and and then you have
different bounds or different community
in the graph
and yeah most of these are really open
so um yep I have a lot of flies but I
think that should be it for the first uh
tutorial where the bond was set up and a
lot of open questions so in the later
ones I'm going to try to make use of the
polymetry bond to do something
interesting with them
[Applause]
yes please here can you go back to the
inequalities between the bones you had
the one side we had all the different
bonds with inequalities can you just go
back to that let me just give you a more
completely
uh yeah sure so my question is do you
have examples for all of them where's
the inequality is strict or other still
so for all of them you you have
extensions
yeah we have examples of every one of
them to be strict and kind of the
graphics is unbounded
us
last yes it's definitely interesting it
will be on full conjecture
so some of the Frameworks that we
discussed here can be used to uh
the only difference is that instead of
maximizing over h of all variables you
just maximize it over each of the subset
of variables
and everything
okay
okay then let's just thank Punk
[Applause]